hi everyone welcome to another episode
of Science and Technology q a for kids
and others
let's see I see a bunch of saved up
questions here I see one from Cameron
from Ollie
do you think it's possible to sustain
life on Mars how far in the future do
you see this happening
well
uh
you know I think the the first thing to
understand
is what does it mean to sustain life I
mean people manage to uh hang out in the
you know in the space station for you
know a year at a time it's that's a very
closed system where you know any any
food that was needed is is uh is sort of
being delivered and um there's a uh
there's a a certain
it's it's not something where one is
kind of where one feels that it is some
sort of an independently sustaining life
on the other hand at some level you know
the Earth is an independent place where
life is sustained in the sense that you
know we we uh breathe in oxygen we
breathe out carbon dioxide the plants do
kind of the opposite
um we have in the end a self-sustaining
system that um uh can be independent of
everything else and where we can have
everything we need to sustain life
you know people have tried to do
experiments where you sort of have a
closed object in which life can be
sustained
um you know there are these nice sort of
what are they called these sort of
globes that you can get which have um
various kinds of Critters inside them
plants and animals inside them and they
seem to be able to be sort of a closed
glass enclosure
um where the only kind of external uh
input is uh is light from the sun or
whatever else
um and I think those for a few years
those managed to maintain themselves as
sort of a a closed ecosystem there was
an experiment uh called Biosphere 2 it
was done in Arizona or when was it 20
something years ago more than that
actually now 30 years ago
um which was an attempt to
kind of have a a sort of a big
Greenhouse type thing where
um it would be possible to have um uh
humans hang out inside in a completely
closed ecosystem it did not work very
well
um all sorts of things weren't wrong I
happened to visit that that place um
it's now uh kind of um uh open to
visitors and things it's no longer a an
attempted closed ecosystem but um uh in
fact I think the um uh when it was
attempted to make this thing where it
would have its own sort of uh
um its its own plants and some uh some
animal life and humans and so on it
didn't succeed I don't know how long it
lasted a couple of years maybe
um and then all sorts of all sorts of
things started going wrong oxygen levels
started uh
um getting out of the range where it was
good for people and things like this so
not a great not a great sample of Let's
Make A a closed human habitable
ecosystem that can just last forever
when it comes to to Mars
um you know the first thing one thinks
about is does one make kind of a
biosphere two greenhouse on Mars where
there's kind of uh sort of standard
atmosphere inside and where one has
plants and things going
um I think the the movie The Martian
featured and a um another
kind of sample of uh uh kind of
fictionalized attempt to do that
um I think uh the the other question is
I mean Mars itself has a thin atmosphere
um that uh uh is certainly not
sufficient for us humans the the
surprising thing in the Martian
atmosphere is that yes you can it's uh
you can fly a drone there the the Mars
helicopter successfully flew there
although it's a pretty exotic object
that has you know uh it's it's it's
rotors rotate uh at the at the speed of
sound there and things like that but it
did successfully you know fly in the
atmosphere
um like you could uh uh fly a drone on
on Earth the question is whether given
Mars as it is can one
expect to Somehow mine what's there and
on the long term kind of have something
where you have sort of an independent uh
human settlement there or something that
doesn't rely on deliveries of stuff from
Earth
and again that that relies on having I
think this kind of greenhouse bubble
type thing
um probably uh people
there's near the um uh there there is uh
there is ice on Mars so you can in
principle get water
um and uh the thing that same with the
moon actually that that in the the South
Pole of the moon for example there's
supposedly ice there and um the the
thing that's exciting about that if
you're going to use for example the moon
as a waste Station to get to other
places is that potentially you can take
that water which is you know H2O with
hydrogen and oxygen and you can
potentially use sunlight as an energy
source to break that down so that you
get separate hydrogen and oxygen which
you can then use as fuel and oxidant for
a rocket
um so you can sort of make your own
rocket fuel
um on the moon and I think also on Mars
um I think that the um the effort to um
uh
May Come
um uh things you know make other things
out of what's there on Mars I'm not sure
how how well that can be done I mean the
the other question would be can you take
something which is something like life
on Earth and uh somehow have a version
of it that works in the environment of
Mars I think the the effort that people
talk about to do that is something which
I really don't know whether the physics
of this works which is take the ice caps
of Mars
um and somehow you know blow them up
with uh uh hydrogen bombs or something
and use that to put enough water vapor
into the atmosphere of Mars that you
have a quite different kind of chemistry
of the atmosphere that maybe is more
able to support life but I I don't know
if that really works
um I think that's one of those things
where you have to try to doing the
calculation is hard
um doing knowing sort of what's going to
happen if if you if you do something
like that is difficult just like on
Earth you know people wonder oh you uh
you know there are lots of nuclear
explosions on Earth do you if you if you
if you had lots of nuclear explosions on
Earth would you put dust into the upper
atmosphere that would make the Surface
cold for years and all sorts of other
things like that and nobody I think
really quite knows
um what would happen under those
circumstances it's one of these things
where there's things that one can
readily compute using kind of what we
know about physics and those things
where well there's this effect does that
affect it's hard to know how things will
come out I think the other the other
place that's interesting to look at in
terms of this process of so-called
terraforming making a planet uh sort of
more like Earth is Venus which has thick
clouds
um and a very high surface temperature
what 350 degrees Centigrade I think
um and people talk about the possibility
of putting microorganisms in the clouds
on on Venus and having their sort of
biochemical processes
um be able to take what exists on Venus
in terms of uh
um the uh what is it I think it has a
bunch of methane and things on it
um and uh and carbon dioxide
um
and being able to kind of biochemically
process that into something that um uh
that's more suitable for life I mean the
thing to understand is there's ordinary
chemistry and there's biochemistry
what's the difference between them
ordinary chemistry the typical thing
one's looking at is there are molecules
that say in a gas for example there are
molecules that are jiggling around and
every so often two molecules will
collide with each other and perhaps
those molecules will be such that
there'll be a chemical reaction in the
sense that there'll be some some forces
that are associated with the electrons
in the atoms that will make those atoms
for example combine so that you might
have I don't know hydrogen and oxygen
and you might combine them into into
water or something like this this can
happen in ordinary chemistry just
because the molecules happen to run into
each other then sort of that's kind of
plain ordinary chemistry the thing that
really became clear perhaps 150 years
ago or something now is this idea of
catalysts in chemistry where instead of
just having the molecules sort of
randomly running around in a gas or in a
liquid you say let's have a catalyst
let's have a in that case a solid
surface that has some kind of topography
to it where the molecules will will
stick on the surface and the the they
will get aligned in some way and then
when another molecule comes along that
molecule will be arranged in such a way
that yes the second molecule fits in and
you're more likely to have a chemical
reaction whereas in if they're in the
gas the molecules are kind of you know
tumbling all always around and if it
turns out to be the case that the
molecules have to be aligned in a
certain way the reaction to be able to
occur the chance of that happening is
much lower so the big trick that biology
has is it has things like enzymes which
are molecules where you can with sort of
the the they are they are arranging
other molecules in just the right
orientation to be able to undergo some
comical reaction and there's a huge
effect from that I mean the the
there can be reactions that happen
trillions of times faster or more
because of the presence of enzymes the
presence of these sort of molecular
catalysts that sort of uh do this
organization of molecules in just the
right way and I think one of the things
we learn more and more about biology is
that you might think of biology as sort
of an extension of chemistry but really
it's much more machine oriented than
that it's much more that molecules are
being organized and you know that
they're going in some filament or
something there will be molecules that
are that are you know it picks up a
molecule that has some process that
actively moves it down the filament
rather than just this thing that happens
in ordinary chemistry where things just
sort of run around randomly and so
that's why it makes a makes sense to say
oh let's put microorganisms which are
doing biochemistry which are doing
things that involve enzymes and other
other kinds of things that are sort of
orchestrated or organizational molecules
um to do something like terraforming
Venus rather than just saying that's put
some chemicals into the and and hope for
the best so to speak I mean this is a
general trend of of uh the thing that we
don't really know yet how to do is uh
molecular scale
um is is doing kind of nanotechnology
where we are organizing what molecules
do rather than just saying oh molecules
are running around and we have chemical
reactions happening we've already
managed to do a huge number of important
technological things just using ordinary
chemistry although many of the reactions
that are the most important industrially
also use catalysts Solid Surfaces where
you have um uh where these molecules get
get sort of macroscopic large-scale
Solid Surfaces where molecules get sort
of organized in their orientation and so
on and as I say biology has sort of gone
one step further because it has
molecular scale things like that
but I think the thing that one
increasingly has to think about is you
know how do we make molecular scale
Machinery that is the kind of thing that
we have in biology and biology has some
pretty nifty little devices like the
ribosome which is the thing that um
actually sort of starts the synthesis of
proto-organizes from from a piece of RNA
that specifies what sequence of amino
acid units should be put together to
make a protein that specifies what that
uh it is the Machinery that has a a
stream of RNA going in and it
progressively extrudes
um uh protein
um that is assembled according to the
pattern that's specified by the RNA
that's a mechanism that's kind of
molecular scale piece of Machinery that
biology has evolved um and it's been
kind of the same for a really long time
in biology
but um
that's kind of the the thing to to
wonder about is how do we make kind of
molecular scale Machinery that does
useful things and compelling one Trend
that was around in the 1980s was this
kind of which led to the term
nanotechnology was this idea that we
would take things that we know about on
a large scale like you know like levers
and gears and things like that and find
ways to make things like that out of
molecules
um that's one possibility the other
possibility is to have things that don't
sort of mechanically work the same way
that large-scale Machinery works but
it's more suitable to be implemented in
molecules so that's kind of a different
approach and if you want to make things
that for example do computation you
don't we we don't typically have
mechanical computers you don't need to
make computation out of something that
is for example mechanical it's sort of
that was the that was the plan in the
1830s 1840s you know Charles Babbage
um that was kind of the the idea of the
analytical engine was let's make this
thing out of cogs and and gears and so
on and have it be able to do
computations that way and you know be
able to add numbers people knew how to
add numbers from the 1600s actually by
using sort of cogs and and things
um but be able to do other kinds of
mathematical operations and be able to
sort of specify the controls purely
mechanically
um that definitely went out of fashion
when electrical devices came in because
it's a lot easier to run electrons
around wires than it is to have actual
Machinery where you're running where
you're moving in cogs and so on the big
problem actually with cogs is very
simple problem to explain if you have an
adding machine and it's it has all the
the digits represented by each digit is
represented by a Cod and you've got the
number 9999999 and then you're going to
add one to it and you move that last Cog
you have to somehow transmit the Force
to cause it to move that carry digit so
that all the 99999s turn into one zero
zero zero zero zero you have to you have
to propagate that force all the way down
that chain and that's the system
mechanically hard thing to do to both
have it be working so that you can just
be moving one Cog at a time and where
you're moving all those I don't know
what you know 10 cogs or something like
that all at a time much easier to do
electronically with electronic switches
and so on where you're just moving
electrons around rather than having to
move material objects around but so the
the way that uh you know our computers
got developed is all based on electrons
and electronics and so on and sort of
the key component that you need is some
kind of switch some kind of thing where
the uh whether electrons can go this way
depends on whether there are electrons
trying to go uh sort of at 90 degrees
the other way so to speak and originally
that was that was done uh well in in
modern computers the key pieces
so-called Field Effect transistors which
have that feature that when you put kind
of voltage
um across
them it prevents uh the um electrons
from flowing through the other way and
that that kind of switching mechanism is
is sort of the key thing that you need
to make logic and to make a computer
it's also the thing you need to make
amplification because when you're saying
oh I've got the small effect and I'm
using the small effect that's kind of
gating this big current that's how you
amplify things because you're saying
small effect has a has an effect on this
big thing that's happening and that's
how you do amplification that was
originally invented first for vacuum
tubes so
in a vacuum tube instead of
um instead of having something where you
have electrons flowing through a
semiconductor a solid semiconductor you
have electrons that were emitted from a
hot wire and just streaming through a
vacuum
um and being uh being gated by the
presence of other wires that produced
electric fields or magnetic fields and
so on I think electric Fields primarily
in the case of vacuum tubes that was a
technology from around
um 1900 1910
um kind of time frame where the um uh
you would um where you're having
electrons flowing through instead of
flowing in a semiconductor so I mean in
in a typical electric circuit
um the electrons are flowing in wires
that are made of metals like copper and
so on in a computer sort of the the
innovation in a sense is having them
flowing through semiconductors which
don't conduct electricity like a copper
wire does whether that trans flow pretty
freely through the wire but they they
only sort of conditionally conduct
electricity only when certain conditions
are met does the electrons go through
and in the case of the earlier
technology one was using electrons going
through a vacuum same technology has
made cathode ray tubes which were the
kind of early approach to televisions
while they approach to televisions until
pretty much the 1990s or or so
um but uh vacuum tubes were you know a
typical vacuum tube you would have um uh
these these things that were like a few
inches tall and they were glass things
with with typically glowing wires inside
when I was a kid for example it was
still the case that lots of what lots of
devices had vacuum tubes in them and you
kind of open up them up and you could
see these glowing uh glowing things one
of the problems with vacuum tubes
whenever you have something like well
it's like a light bulb like an
incandescent light bulb where you
actually have a hot wire inside
something which is essentially a vacuum
typically like bulbs housing on gas in
them but um
but uh you know that that the rate of
failure of the wire just breaking for
example is quite High nothing like that
happens in semiconductors and
semiconductors you can expect that that
solid object will sort of last forever
but anyway the you know the basic
approach that's used for computers is
you've got lots of electrons flowing
around in these kind of uh
wire-like things in a semiconductor and
you've got this elaborate pattern I've
kind of uh switches and um and so on
between these wires that's so it's
really that the story of computers is
really the story of kind of um
navigating electrons through through
well a modern microprocessor is kind of
um uh has the sort of density of wires
and and and switches and Gates and so on
that is more than you would get if you
were to make a sort of Street a city
that covered the whole earth and look at
its street map so to speak uh modern
microplusters have have more circuitry
in them than that but it's that sort of
kind of roads and and and Junctions and
so on that are happening but um it's all
about moving electrons around biology is
doing something a bit similar but it's
more about moving molecules around
um and atoms around rather than moving
just electrons around and it has kind of
all this apparatus for arranging oh
you've got you know a surface of a cell
and it's transporting you know potassium
into it and it's going through little
little little
microscopic tubes that were formed in
the in the membrane around the cell
things like this form those microscopic
tubes formed by proteins that just have
sort of holes in the middle of them and
and push the potassium through or
whatever else it is
so I mean the the kind of thing one
thinks about is that that's kind of the
um that's the mechanism is uh you know
how do you make kind of molecular scale
uh Machinery that does those kinds of
things you know one thing that we know
from biology there is some Machinery in
biology that looks very much like kind
of large-scale uh gears and lovers type
Machinery like for example in bacteria
there are flagella these these things
that kind of make the bacteria able to
swim and they're these little tails that
they have that rotate around like the
kind of like the screw of a ship or
something
um and the way those work is they
actually have something that looks
really like a gear that um and it really
has I think it even has 13 I think it
has 13 teeth usually or something
um and you know you look at another
electron microscope and you can kind of
see it and it really looks just like the
kind of uh you know gears that we might
make out of metal or something like this
it's not made out of metal it's made out
of protein and it's made out of a
particular protein where when the
protein sort of uh folds itself up it
forms that particular shape
one of the recent Innovations last few
weeks I suppose people have been talking
about is the idea of well how do you
make a designer protein how do you make
a protein that's a certain shape if you
did want to make a protein that is you
know some kind of gear shape or if you
don't want to make a protein that has
some particular form how do you do it
it's hard to know so protein consists of
the these amino acids which are clumps
of molecule of atoms and uh 20 roughly
different kinds of amino acids and a
protein is formed from a linear sequence
a linear chain of those amino acids and
all the different proteins we have I
know and as humans we have like I know
30 40 000 kinds of proteins that make us
up
um and uh these um
those are specified by a DNA but in the
end the proteins are sequences of amino
acids and they might be long sequences
you know they might be hundreds of
thousands of of amino acids or they
might be short hundreds of amino acids
or something like this but what happens
is there's this chain of amino acids and
it is it happens to be the case that
those uh chains they're pretty flexible
and they fold themselves up and the way
they fold themselves up depends on the
the different amino acids have different
amounts of Attraction for other amino
acids and so on particularly they're two
kinds that hydrophobic and hydrophilic
hydrophobic are ones that kind of push
away from water hydrophilical ones that
kind of go towards water and so those
are those are two features that if you
put a protein in in water it'll tend to
have its its hydrophobic pieces sort of
on the inside and hydrophilic pieces on
the outside I think
um and that that's um uh uh you know
that's one feature of how the thing
folds up but this this problem of how
does a protein fold up it's been a hard
problem because it's kind of like well
there are many different configurations
it could fold up in you want to find the
one that has the lowest energy the one
where the most kind of uh proteins that
amino acids that want to be together are
together the most where the amino acids
that want to be a part or apart those
kinds of things and that
that question of sort of how do you find
that minimum energy configuration the
protein is flopping around how does it
you know it it uh it will find that in
in actual biology in you know if you
actually make a protein it will fold
itself up usually into its mineral
energy configuration fairly quickly but
the question is if we're trying to just
do that in a computer and work out what
will happen how do we do it it's worth
explaining that actually proteins don't
always fold themselves up in exactly the
right way and in fact there are some
nasty diseases that happen from
misfolding of proteins and in actual
biology needless to say biology has all
kinds of mechanisms for making sure
proteins fold up correctly and they're a
so-called chaperone molecules for
example which are used to guide the
folding of proteins and things like this
but in the first approximation you have
a protein it's going to fold up in a
particular shape by the way the protein
may not be rigidly folded it may flop
around it may depend on whether it's in
water and things like this but first
approximation it's going to fold in a
certain shape often the way you figure
out what shape it folded into it is by
making a crystal of the protein where
you have many many copies of that
protein molecule all arranged in a
regular array and then you can use x-ray
crystallography to figure out what that
regular array is and to deduce what the
shape of the protein is that way but and
so it's a bit of a different environment
than a protein that's hanging out in
water which is what it typically does in
biology but anyway so so this question
of how does the protein fold up it's a
it's a difficult thing to figure out
because you could say well let's just
try all the configurations and see which
one has the lowest energy but there are
an immense number of possible
configurations if the protein is sort of
a length n protein there tend to be
exponential of n uh roughly kinds of
configurations to have to test
so uh people have been trying for ages
to figure out sort of what are good ways
to to figure out how proteins will fold
then a few years ago uh kind of machine
learning methods
um seemed to um
seem to win the day uh people have been
trying that for a long time it finally
really worked and what does it mean that
machine learning methods figure out how
proteins fold well uh in a sense what
what's happening is
um the uh there's a there's a large
amount of data on how proteins that have
been studied fold up and so what you're
really trying to do when you say how is
this protein going to fold what actually
happens in these machine learning
systems like Alpha fold and Rosetta uh
fold and whatever it's these various
other different um uh folding machine
Learning Systems what they're typically
doing is Step number one compare the
thing you just fed in the amino acid
sequence you just fed in with all known
proteins and particularly when you look
at the amino acid sequence that was fed
in you know look at different sections
of it and say look at each section and
say how does each section compare with
sections of proteins well we know how
they they folded up so that's step
number one so that actually takes a lot
of data you have to have I don't know
maybe a terabyte of data associated with
kind of everything that's known about
how all the known proteins fold up
that's step one step two is okay so you
know that this particular region looks
like a region of some other protein and
it folded in this way but how do you now
glue together these little pieces where
you say well this might fold this way
because we saw it folded that way in
this particular example that was already
studied now you have to kind of glue all
those pieces together that's the main
place where kind of the machine learning
kind of approach comes in is that gluing
together step and and sort of figuring
out how do you how do you arrange these
pieces so they so they make sense
together it's kind of kind of similar
when you look at an image generation uh
machine learning AI system and you say
you know you want uh uh I don't know I I
asked one of these systems to make a
picture of a crocodile dancing on the
moon yesterday and so it's got to figure
out you know it knows what the moon
surface of the Moon looks like it knows
what a crocodile looks like maybe it
knows what sort of a configuration of a
of a of a person or a critter dancing
looks like it has to sort of merge
together those Concepts and make
something which is a reasonable merger
of those Concepts and did a surprisingly
good job actually kind of a funny
picture
um but uh that that's sort of the one of
the things that machine learning is good
at is kind of sort of take these pieces
and kind of smoosh them together in a
plausible way and that's what has to be
done in the case of proteins as well
strangely enough the the same kind of
smoosh things together and figure out
how they they fit
um that is being used for language
models for figuring out oh we've started
you know we start by saying off saying
something like you know the best thing
about AI is how are you going to
continue that well you what you want to
do is you might take you might know that
if you look look on the on the web there
are you know 100 sentences that kind of
start more or less that way not quite
that way and you say well here are
roughly their continuations and then the
big thing that you want to do with with
sort of machine learning is to figure
out how do you how do you correctly
merge what you what you've seen with um
uh with what's already there and that's
what you know in in a sense that's how
you can think about the large language
models that make chat gbt and things
work that's sort of what they're doing
is this process of merging things
together in a reasonable way and one of
the sort of interesting features is that
these large language models when applied
to proteins which are after all have
nothing to do with human language and so
on they seem to have the same they seem
to have the ability to to do this kind
of merging process that you need and
have it sort of be reasonable for
proteins just like it's reasonable for
language it's not completely clear why
that works it could be what's happening
in both cases is that there's some kind
of regularity in how things work work
that we haven't yet discovered that you
know in Biochemistry we haven't yet
discovered that there is some some very
uh regular feature of how proteins are
put together which isn't obvious to us
um but which um
uh which we can um uh which the machine
learning system has detected just like
it's it's likely that there are features
of human language which are there but
haven't really been well codified by us
just like we know about things like the
grammar of human language in a noun verb
noun and things is a typical thing we
don't know about the kind of the meaning
related similar sort of ways that things
get constructed in a general fashion and
that's perhaps what these machine
Learning Systems have effectively found
for us implicitly and that's how they
kind of how they manage to work but one
of the things I said something that was
just been talked about in the last few
weeks has been maybe a month or so now
um has been the idea of can you make a
designer protein by for example just
giving as you do for these kind of
generated images you say just make me a
protein that will have a nickel atom
inside it with a cage and will open
itself up if you do this sort of that is
it plausible to do that particularly if
you read the biological literature which
has a bunch of text in it that says oh
this is what happens and here's a
molecule that does that and so on and I
think one of the things that looks
somewhat promising that you can
essentially be able to uh sort of just
like you can synthesize an image you can
imagine a crocodile dancing on the moon
or whatever you can synthesize that
image and have the the AI kind of put
the it knows what the sort of
fundamental pieces are puts them
together in a plausible way so something
similar may be possible with molecules
with biological molecules with proteins
um that you can say well you've got with
one piece that you know fits nickel
atoms inside it or something another
piece that attaches to this now this
this uh AI system will be able to merge
those together to make you something
where it says okay here's an amino acid
sequence just make that amino acid
sequence and you'll make a protein that
has these particular properties it's
kind of an interesting direction for
sort of thinking about
nanotechnology a molecular scale
Machinery I mean the the the the the
most important place for us uh where
molecular scale Machinery is obviously
useful is an interfacing to biology
um because you know we are essentially
giant molecular scale machines which
have all of these little mechanisms
going on inside and the question is uh
particularly when something goes wrong
with some of those mechanisms can you go
in from the outside and put in
technology that fixes those things and
yes you can do that by having sort of
large-scale things that you know
large-scale uh objects that um uh are at
our sort of macroscopic machine scale
but it's much more interesting and
potentially more more effective if you
can have something which is write down
the molecular scale a machine that was
sort of constructed by you know designed
by us in an engineering kind of well
designed for a particular purpose which
turns out to be biologically useful so
anyway I think that went quite far
afield from the original question that
was asked here
um
let's see Diana comments maybe
biological switches would change
everything for a biological machine yeah
you know I actually don't know it's a
good question what the analog of a sort
of biological switch really is I mean
there are certainly molecules that will
do things like they will have a
protecting group that that prevents some
other molecule from getting at this
piece that would cause a reaction to
happen I think maybe one can think about
that a little bit like a switch but it's
a good question and it's a good question
whether there are
um
what the analog of an amplifier is oh
well actually we know an example PCR
the polymerase chain reaction is an
example of a biological or molecular
amplifier where you start with you know
one piece of of DNA and you end up with
lots of them
um and uh
um the uh that that's that's an example
of where
um of sort of a a molecular scale
amplifier where in that particular case
it's one molecule you end up with lots
of molecules it's a little bit different
from the way that um that electron type
switches work
um where it's not like you're getting
more electrons you're getting a
different flow of electrons have to
think about what the biological analog
of that is I'm not sure
um interesting interesting thought
um
let's see there's a question here from
Universe within can can can you explain
the fundamental principles of biology
um
you know I think this point about
Machinery at the molecular scale that
really in some sense is the big idea of
biology
is that
uh you can have kind of controlled
things happening at a molecular scale
now the actual mechanisms by which that
works uh you know we have this idea of
of DNA where we can kind of store the
program of how we set things up and then
this idea of proteins of of kind of
molecules which can be of different
shapes where the shape is determined by
this kind of uh computation like
sequence that's on the molecule I mean
that idea of make a molecule in a
certain shape uh have a sort of a a a a
standardized way to make molecules of
different shapes that's a that's an
interesting concept where uh kind of
you've got I mean one kind of Wonders
what the analog of that concept is for
something like robotics you say oh I
want a robot that's going to be all
kinds of different shapes
um how do I make that you know can I
have the snake that has um that just has
articulation that causes it to kind to
sneak around in all different ways kind
of the analog of a protein you know that
will be one way I suppose to imagine
making a um uh kind of an amusing way to
imagine making a robot I wonder whether
that could be made to work
um where the thing is just one long
snake and you know it articulates and
you'd have might have a you know a
million elements in the thing and it
articulates well you can make all kinds
of shapes out of that um you could make
kind of a space filling curve where the
snake has kind of snaked around and and
filled up this ball even though it's
just a one-dimensional thing just like a
ball of of wool or something like that
you're you're snaking it around to make
this sort of three-dimensional object
and then you might imagine oh you could
also make a completely different shape
you could um I mean in a sense I suppose
you know any old piece of knitting or
crochet or something like that is going
to be a thing where you're taking this
one-dimensional object and you're making
it into a different shape but now the
question for robotics would be sort of
can you get there from here that is
you've got this this uh this you know
micro snake thing that makes this kind
of physical object and now you say Okay
I want it to walk you know how does it
how does it get those how does it
dynamically go from a configuration
where the where the feet are in this
position do the configuration with the
feet are in that position interesting
question whether that's possible that
should be an interesting thing to work
out whether you can uh you know if you
imagine something that is purely a
one-dimensional thing folded up is there
a way of changing the fold changing the
orientation of things so that it goes
from the one configuration to another
um I I don't think you know a good
question would be does biology do that
much and the answer is not much I think
most most molecules most proteins in
biology kind of they they go into a
particular configuration and they mostly
are fitting together like jigsaw puzzles
with other proteins or other kinds of
molecules rather than saying let me just
deform myself to have a different
structure
so I think that's some uh that's one
thing I think that um uh the question of
sort of how biology organizes kind of
large-scale uh uh achieves large-scale
things it has all these molecules it has
all this Machinery how does it actually
cause something biologically useful to
happen
um that's an interesting question and I
think less is understood about that than
one might imagine because in a sense one
of the things that's happening is you've
got you know trillions of molecules or
at least uh yeah trillions of molecules
that are all sort of doing things that
are organized together and they're doing
those things in parallel these molecules
it's not like one molecule does
something then another one then another
one
um they're all doing them in parallel
and how one organizes how it even thinks
about all these things happening in
parallel it's difficult a lot of what we
tend to think about as humans is very
sequentialized you know when we talk
with language there's a you know a
one-dimensional chain of of words that
come out it's not that we have lots of
things happening at the same time in our
brains we have you know 100 billion
neurons or whatever and they're kind of
all firing not quite all at the same
time but they're all firing uh you know
it's not like it's just first one set
then another set lots of neurons are
firing at the same time and that's it
that's one big difference for example
when we look at machine Learning Systems
today they one big difference is that
that whereas our memories are kind of
every part is active and doing something
our in our brains the in a computer as
of today the memory is mostly just
sitting there remembering things and
only the CPU is is you know is going
through and actually making changes
whereas in our brains it's kind of like
all CPU all memory all mixed together
but in biology in general there's this
idea of lots of things happening in
parallel and kind of understanding at a
at a sort of large-scale level what's
happening when lots of stuff happens in
parallel allow is something we're not
particularly good at I mean our physics
project actually in recent times has
given sort of some new paradigms for
thinking about what it means for lots of
stuff to happen in parallel one of the
things that we are familiar with is in
our normal experience of the world we
are used to the idea that uh sort of
there is we have space we have kind of
things happening at different places in
space and at some moment in time things
are happening at different places in
space there's like in parallel across
space lots of things are happening at
any given moment in time and we kind of
have some familiarity with that partly
because the speed of light is quite fast
compared to our processes of thinking so
we're used to the idea that we can see
all the stuff that's happening in
different places in space all at the
same time so to speak or all what's
perceived as being at the same time by
our brains because it takes our brains a
long time to kind of say oh yeah I I I
got that and then go on for the next
thing and the speed of light is such
that it's delivering information about
uh things that are happening in
different places in space sort of all
together as far as we're concerned so we
have some awareness of sort of that
parallelism when it comes to things
happening in different places in space
but quite how biology organizes these
kinds of um these kinds of things is not
really known and in
an example of something that is not well
understood is when you have molecules
that are bumping around or maybe they're
being organized in a sort of
machine-like way and you ask the
question uh you know how fast is such
and such a chemical process can happen
the usual way you work that out is you
say well if it involves some amount of
this chemical some amount of that
chemical it's the you know you have
concentrations of these two chemicals
you multiply them together that's the
number of combined uh sort of pairs of
chemical a and chemical B that they'll
be and that's how you work out how fast
the reaction has happens
but that doesn't account for the fact
that well actually after you know A and
B interacted they're in a sort of
different configuration than before and
you can end up with these kind of chains
of causality of one molecule interacted
with another and then it mattered that
that there was that history that
determined that affected whether the
molecule will interact again and so on
and so on and so on ordinary chemistry
and the ordinary kind of mathematical
methods used for chemistry do not take
account of that I mean in the in the
language of uh of fancy physics they're
essentially doing a mean field Theory
and they're ignoring correlations
um and so the um
the thing that um one can certainly
imagine is what does it look like when
you take account of those causal
relationships one doesn't know how to do
that because that requires kind of
better understanding of sort of how a
parallel process of um uh of of action
happens and that's something we've
learned quite a bit about actually from
our physics project not yet applied well
to biology but those are sort of those
are important principles in biology I
suppose one of the one of the meta
principles of biology is uh just protein
lets you do an awful lot of stuff you
know protein made from you know uh you
know a small number of elements small
number of different kinds of elements
you know these 20 amino acids and just
putting those units together in
different configurations kind of gets
you all the different creatures of the
earth and Etc et cetera et cetera what
biology usually seems to do is most
things are made of protein but then it
kind of recruits some other kinds of
atoms to make you know calcium for bones
or or um you know iron for red blood
cells or uh you know iodine for the
thyroid gland or whatever else it
usually recruits other kinds of atoms
that have particular useful chemical
properties and usually usually what it
does is it it makes a cage out of
protein and just the right size to fit
that kind of atom and enough atoms are
sort of bumping around and come from
your food and things like that that the
ones that are the right size will get
stuck in those cages and will do the
right chemical thing that biology is
sort of recruiting for but I think
that's the um
uh it's kind of my my view of sort of
the the mechanism of biology and one of
the things you see in biology is is once
you have some process some molecule that
interacts with some other molecule that
does this and that and the other biology
will tend to reuse that same idea over
and over and over again
so for example ideas like uh sort of
um natural selection the the evolution
by a natural selection that things
um are uh that if you want to kind of
adapt to the environment you can do that
by saying well you know the more adapted
organism will have more children and
that means that and and that means that
it's um uh eventually its genetics will
take over the population that idea which
is applied at a large scale for overall
biology is applied at a small scale in
the immune system and it's kind of like
biology reusing an idea
um that uh that existed there and you
could say it you know we put it in a
very human answer you know form of
saying it's reusing the idea really it's
just that is a feature of sort of the
fundamental formal computational feature
of how things work and that mechanism
appears both in large-scale biology and
in sort of the small scale immune system
um
let's see
I've been talking a whole bunch about
biology here but um
um
uh
and I mean I think the um
William comments aren't neurons the
biological analog of switches
uh yeah yeah they're an example I mean
but they are again electrical a neuron
is the what's happening in a neuron is
it's like a little tiny battery it's
electrochemical device where you know
you you have a chemical signal from one
neuron and it uh you know the one neuron
might might connect with ten thousand
other neurons and if it arranges if they
write electrical signals accumulate that
the next neuron down the line will sort
of uh
um you know we'll we'll start getting
excited and they'll start producing
electrical pulses and then it will
excite another neuron and so on in the
end those um uh the um the you know the
battery that is the neuron that is
making electrical pulses is eventually
fueled by glucose and you know it it's
it's it's it's taking in food
effectively and that's how it's
generating uh it's producing it has the
energy to um uh to go and produce those
electrical pulses
um
let's see
uh
gosh lots of comments and questions here
um
well there's a slightly technical
question here but perhaps it's
interesting to talk about question is
can machine learning help uh solving
inverse scattering problems where the
forward scattering problem is highly
non-linear
so what that's about is if you have
a
um
something where let's say you have
you
have some kind of explosion
inside the earth and it produces seismic
waves it produces deformations in the in
the rock that propagate like sound waves
like sound waves propagate in the air
there are there are similar seismic
waves that propagate through Rock and
you've um and you're you're you know
it's probably going through the Rock and
eventually you pick up sort of the
signal of what uh all those
um what what all the the results of that
whole process of of the seismic waves
propagating through the Rock and the
question is given that you picked up you
can work out if the rock had this
particular form if you had Granite here
and you had Limestone here and so on you
could work out uh from the um uh you
know knowing explosion happened here
this is the rock that was here and there
you could work out okay so this would be
the signal that I would get on the
surface based on that kind of rock so
now the question is to solve the inverse
problem of I've got these signals what
kind of lockers down there and that's
important if you're trying to prospect
for minerals and and things like this
and so the problem is that one of the
problems with that is there may not be a
unique answer there may be many
different answers which would lead to
the same pattern of of signals at the
surface and one of the things I think is
being suggested here is you know can
machine learning be used as a way to say
what's the plausible reconstruction of
uh kind of what rock there could be
because there may be that there's a a
version of the rock that would produce
those signals at the surface but it's
some weird formation that's never
actually seen in geology so yes I think
that's a good use case for machine
learning I've wondered about
um some similar use cases one famous use
case is the is the use case for x-ray
crystallography so if you take a um a
molecule like a protein for example make
a crystal I mentioned this before you're
making a crystal where you just have a
thing where you have this complicated to
shape protein and you've arranged in a
completely regular array you've made a
solid out of that protein where the
protein is all it's all lined up it's
all in this regular array then it turns
out there's this technique of X-ray
crystallography you scatter x-rays from
that some from that system and the
x-rays are probe certain features of
that that crystal structure and the
question is then okay what is the actual
shape of protein based on the the the
ways that the x-rays scatter so for
example when DNA when the structure of
DNA was was decoded in 1953 the big
innovation was well a person called
Roslyn Franklin had had um had found the
x-ray crystallography images of this is
what you get if you've crystallized DNA
which is a hard thing to do
um and then you've uh you've done X-ray
crystallography on it these are the ways
that x-rays scatter from that Crystal so
then the question is okay what shape of
molecule will make x-rays scatter that
way and there are many different
solutions there can be all kinds of
weird shapes that would produce the same
x-ray crystallography pattern and the
thing that Jim Watson Francis Crick did
was to figure out that well actually if
you have this shape that is this double
helix that will produce the X-ray
crystallography pattern that was
actually observed in um to be the X-ray
crystallography pattern of DNA there
would be many other possible solutions
but that was the one that is molecularly
plausible to make and so this idea of
using machine learning as the way to do
that inversion it's a good idea there
are cases where that inversion is done
which don't need machine learning so
famous cases tomography for CT scanning
and MRI and so on uh what's done there
is that's sort of a a simpler case of
inverse scattering where what you have
is okay you've got x-rays they're going
through a person
um the the x-rays you know when they hit
bone for example the x-rays don't go
through as much as when they're going
through softer suit
um and uh so if you if you kind of you
know if you X-ray your hand this was the
early thing that Rankin did around 1900
was you X-ray your hand you see the the
bones are white well because of the way
the film was being used the that's the
place where the x-rays didn't go through
um and but that's where you shine the
x-rays from one side and you see what
what comes through and the answer is uh
where you have soft tissue the x-rays
come through where you have bone the
x-rays don't come through so the the
basic operation is you're you're seeing
you know what's what what do you see on
the other side when you when you shoot
x-ray through something I mean you can
you can um uh so that's the basic
operation now the question is uh how do
you reconstruct the sort of what's
inside you by just you know you can you
can x-ray from one side so to speak and
you can just see kind of the shadow of
what's inside you you know the shadow of
your ribs or whatever else on the X-ray
film
the idea of tomography is to go and look
at from all angles to just go around the
circle and just say for every different
angle how much uh our x-rays absorbed so
you're going in this orientation you're
absorbing this much you go in this
orientation you absorb this much and
essentially what you can think about
doing is imagine that for every
orientation you knew how much how many
x-rays were absorbed and imagine you
were cutting out little I don't know
trans pieces of transparency or
something where you where you make them
darker if more X-rays were absorbed I'll
actually lighter because the X-ray tends
to x-ray film has this inversion thing
but but let's say it's lighter when more
X-rays were absorbed and darker where
fewer X-rays were absorbed you just lay
these strips down in you arrange them
around a circle knowing that in this
orientation you've got this amount
absorbed in this orientation you've got
this amount absorbed if you do that then
the picture you'll get will basically be
a picture of what's inside
um and and that's how tomography works
you know when a CT scanner does its
thing it's going to to tick around it's
just it has a x-ray Source x-ray uh
receiver and it's just finding what's
happening at all different angles MRI is
a little more complicated because there
happens to be a it happens that the the
way that works the the it's a the the
signal is at 90 degrees to where the
whether whether where the magnetic field
is and so on so it's just a slight more
geometrical trickiness but it's the same
basic idea but that's a case where you
can do inverse scattering uh very
definitely in a very mathematical way in
many cases of inverse scattering
um that's because actually because it is
a linear problem it's just the the
amount of extra absorption just kind of
adds up in many of these other cases
nothing like that happens and so yes
it's a I think it is a good use case for
machine learning and um I'm actually
surprised I I mean I've certainly asked
people about the case of extra Crystal
photography and people sort of said yeah
that's a good idea but I'm not sure
anybody's done it
um perhaps they have
but yes it's a good use case because
it's one of these things where it's kind
of the reconstructing what's plausible
particularly based on many examples of
what really is there is is a good kind
of thing to do
um
okay
Kylie was asking how do x-rays work to
see only bones and ignore skin okay so
the basic point is
that it's a question of uh
what what absorbs x-rays more
so for example if you
um well if you
shine a light
flashlight through your hand you'll see
you actually do see something which I
think you can see the bones if you do
that
um the uh you know for visible light
um
well the problem is for visible light
that
the photons of light as they go through
your hand they keep on getting scattered
they keep on getting uh you know going
in a slightly different direction and so
on they don't kind of go straight they
don't most of the time just go straight
through
um and that means that even if there was
a nice you know bone there
um you'll the photons will keep on
getting kicked around in sort of a
random walk and so it'll fuzz out any
image of the bone for x-rays x-rays are
much higher energy photons
um they're usually produced typical
x-ray source of x-rays is you accelerate
electrons
um which you can do in electric field
because they're charged particles you
you accelerate them you crash them into
a target of lead or something else I
should note some other lighter materials
I think are usually used and that will
produce what's called bremstral on
breaking radiation
um and that is uh uh what what will
happen is the the electrons will
um basically excite atoms in the
material and those atoms will emit
X-rays and those x-rays are then you can
then collimate those x-rays to to only
keep the ones that are going into
particular direction and that's how you
get your X-ray Source but anyway the
x-rays are just high energy photons uh
same kind of thing that's in light but
higher energy and those higher energy
photons most of the time when their uh
when they're going many things are
mostly quite transparent to x-rays
things are mostly you know what our hand
for example mostly the x-rays just go
straight through but
the x-rays get uh some atoms some types
of atoms will stop those X-rays and the
basic rule is that the um uh an atom so
if you look on the periodic table you go
hydrogen helium Etc et cetera et cetera
as you go through successive atoms
you'll um you'll find the the um there
are more protons in the nucleus of those
atoms and uh if I'm remembering
correctly the um uh the rate when you
sort of shoot Alexa x-rays through
roughly the um uh the the scattering of
X-rays I think goes like the square of
the atomic number so it's kind of like
it's um uh as you as you make um as you
look at heavier elements they tend to
have more effect on X-rays and uh uh let
me see
why is that that is because
um yeah that's because the um uh the
well okay it's because the the electrons
when there's a larger charge on the
nucleus it's kind of pulling electrons
closer to the nucleus and when you pull
them closer to the nucleus they
effectively have higher energy they're
kind of spinning around more rapidly you
can think of it that way they're kind of
spinning around more rapidly they're
pulled in more by this higher charge
nucleus and so that that causes them to
be uh associated with higher energies
and that means that when you have
um they when the x-rays can be absorbed
there because there's this place where
the where the atom can
um
can have kind of uh that there's the the
electrons in the atom are kind of able
to absorb x-rays that are of higher
energy than in the case where there's a
lower charge on the nucleus and the
electrons are kind of uh uh sort of have
a kind of more uh more lazily going
around the atom and they just don't have
the ability to absorb photons that that
say I'm going to kick you pretty hard
and that those electrons just they can't
absorb that kick in the same way so in
in um uh what what happens is as the as
the atomic number goes up as you go
further in the periodic table
um you absorb x-rays significantly more
and because our bones have calcium in
them
um as opposed to having carbon
oxygen hydrogen which is what most of
our uh sort of soft tissue is made of
um calcium is further along in the
periodic table so it absorbs x-rays more
so we see uh we see x-rays uh we see the
x-rays being stopped there and because
uh originally x-ray stuff was done with
with ordinary photographic film where
the places where it wasn't exposed it
was white that's our bones happen to
show up white
um on um uh
uh on sort of typical x-rays because
that's the place where the the the
x-rays don't get through the film wasn't
exposed back in the day when people were
using photographic film for x-rays
um and and so it ended up White and the
places where the film was exposed it
went and went dark and those are the
places that correspond to our soft
tissue where the x-rays were were just
successfully going through rather than
getting absorbed
um
MRI by the way sees different things so
MRI is all about uh hydrogen and it's
it's all about seeing uh essentially
um the uh it's seeing where where the
hydrogen atoms are
um in in one's body and things like um
other kinds of Imaging Technologies like
um uh there are ones like pet scanning
positron emission tomography
um that is seeing I think glucose
uh let's see
now I think let me think
um that certainly sees where metabolism
is happening but I'm now confusing
myself a little bit because in
um
well in functional MRI imaging for
looking at where in the brain is active
you are seeing glucose metabolism and I
I it still must be primarily uh seeing
what's happening in the presence of
hydrogen atoms
um I have to think about that a little
bit more to see how that works
um
the
Prince is commenting that that
bonapacity comes down to water contents
there's more water and tissue yeah I
think the point is that that
I mean what's happening is the x-rays
are getting
by
I mean the the
yeah water doesn't stop x-rays
um or it does eventually stop x-rays but
at a much uh slower rate than things
like bone I I think it's the calcium
content of bone that is the primary
thing that stops X-rays and for example
if you have um you know if you have a a
metal plate because you you know broke
some bone and it got repaired with metal
plate that will show up the metal will
be higher atomic number and it'll show
up it'll completely stop the x-rays
um
uh
okay y'all YOLO is asking can those
x-rays be used for automatic detection
changes within the molecular structure
of crystallized solids
uh
well x-ray crystallography
is
people don't do that on sort of a
real-time basis it's kind of like it's a
very delicate thing to make these
crystals and it takes a lot of effort
you know people spend a year trying to
crystallize this kind of protein and
it's a big kind of complicated art just
how quickly do you cool it down so that
the protein molecules sort of arrange
themselves to make into a solid and so
on it doesn't tend to be something where
you just say let's deform it and see
what happens or something it's not a
it's not a real-time kind of uh activity
it's very very slow activity actually
um so I think that the um
um
uh there are
techniques
um
let's see I'm trying to remember how
this works uh there's an ex AFS except
what is that
um
x-ray absorption
oh boy
uh
there are various techniques
that are not doing so s crystallography
is based on the fact that there's a
regular array and you're effectively
detecting the periodicity of the array
they're detecting different
periodicities in the array
mathematically you're doing a Fourier
transform
um the uh what what you're saying is the
atoms in this orientation the atoms are
arranged in this regular kind of
sequence in this orientation they're
arranged in this in this sequence that's
roughly what you're detecting an
asteroid crystallography
um I don't think
gosh there are techniques for looking at
very fast molecular processes and I
think there's one that involves x-rays
but I'm not um I'm not remembering how
that works right now
um
let's see
huh
um
Universe with him asks do you think
ecology will play an important role in
understanding molecular computation
interesting I mean the question is what
do we know from ecology and are there is
this sort of cross-pollination of of
things we know from ecology about oh I
don't know you know what's the invasive
species analog in molecular Computing or
at the level of molecular biology
um I'm not sure I think that ecology is
still a comparatively blunt science I
mean we know the sort of mathematical
aspects of ecology are mostly things
about Game Theory mostly things about
saying well we've got this number of
this species and that number of that
species then this will happen I mean
there are there are very fundamental
problems in ecology which are completely
unsolved like uh you know for example
why isn't there always one winning
species how do you estimate how many
different species there will be within a
given uh area I mean there are there are
weird rules like these claims that on
Islands the number of species depending
if you have a small island you have
different number of species and there's
some kind of power our law distribution
I'm not sure if that data is correct
it's probably rather hard data to get
that um uh you know on different sort of
sizes of islands and things you'll get
different numbers of species and uh
there are all these kinds of things that
are observed about sort of the the
number of species that exist like for
example there are perhaps 10 million
species of of Critters on the Earth
estimate that 10 million number you know
the Earth is a certain size at certain
age
Etc et cetera et cetera why is it 10
million why is it not a trillion why is
it not a thousand
um you know why are there different uh
numbers of species what what is the
relationship between
um
well we see we see speciation happening
we see the the formation of distinct
species
um and you know exactly uh what what
determines kind of this whole uh sort of
interaction between different species
what determines
um uh you know can we have a in a sense
a new species
often involves an innovation in some
Niche it figures out you know the the
new kind of bird figures out how to how
to Peck its way into this kind of nut or
something
um and it's sort of an idea and it's
kind of like how do we explain the space
of ideas how do we describe sort of how
how these different species Each of
which sort of has an idea what is that
space of ideas and how do we think about
how that fits together you know we have
we have a more microscopic version of
this in microorganisms for example when
you have a bacterial Colony you know if
you look at I don't know the the gut
microbiome or something you're looking
at all these different bacterial species
there
um and how they interact with each other
and you know if you eat a lot of this
kind of food they'll that it'll make an
environment which is more rich and
whatever and then um uh you'll you'll
end up um you'll end up changing that
microbiome and how that works and what
the Ecology of that is is sort of a a
perhaps uh more immediately
experimentally accessible version of
ecology I mean there's also ecological
issues and things like cancer and so on
uh with different types of uh of of
cells being produced and such like
um I actually realized that I have to
um uh
disappear here because I have to go do
some day job things
um and uh
um
I noticed Satan commenting that ecology
is more complicated than physics I
wonder how true that is you see what
happens in physics is like all these gas
molecules are bouncing around in the
room they're doing really complicated
things it's just that the particular
observation we make of them about their
overall pressure or overall uh flow is
one where that complexity is hidden so
in ecology the issue is what do we care
about and if the things we care about
include how many humans survive on this
on this part of the planet
um you know that may be something that
which rubs our noses perhaps quite
literally into kind of the computational
irreducibility and all this kind of
complexity of what's going on but there
may be some questions we can ask in
ecology if we could figure out what
those questions are well we could say
yeah we got a science answer for that
just like we can have a sort of simple
science answer for these kind of
large-scale features of gases anyway
lots of interesting questions thank you
for asking those I see many more about
different topics and I look forward to
chatting with you all again next week
so thanks bye for now